Asthma is a chronic disease of the lungs...
...and it can occur as early as six months.
It can occur later in life as well.
Normally, the way your lung functions is that you have airways...
...that go from your mouth into your lungs and they end up in little air sacs.
In the normal lung, those tubes are wide open.
It makes it very easy for air to flow in and out.
In somebody with asthma, those tubes or airways are narrow...
...because the wall of the tube is inflamed,...
...so that makes it more difficult to breathe in someone with asthma.
It's like breathing through a straw.
Children with asthma can have different signs, also known as symptoms.
Asthma can look many different ways.
Some children may cough with their asthma.
Some children wheeze.
Some children work really hard to breathe,...
...using their chest muscles and their stomach muscles.
They may cough when they exercise.
They may cough when they go out in the cold air.
Coughing or waking after midnight, in the middle of the night,...
...that's the most severe symptom.